londoners and particularly women have
been failed this review borne out of the
murder of Sarah everard found that even
the policing of her vigil further
damaged confidence
but it also reveals the lack of faith is
shared by many officers one says rape
convictions are so bad it may as well be
legalized there are stories of rape
tests being ruined because of broken
fridges and a female officer who
reported being raped by another officer
who was then forced to work with him
even as we publish this report there
hasn't been a change across the whole of
policing that says anybody that's got
domestic abuse on their record or
anybody that has indecent exposure isn't
automatically removed from the ability
to be a police officer so I think they
should be of course they should be the
report finds a bullying culture
underpins the Met's problems it tells of
initiation rituals with Junior officers
urinated on and one sexually assaulted
in a shower it's ghastly isn't it you
sit down and read that report and it
generates a whole series of emotions it
generates sort of sort of anger
frustration embarrassment
it generates some pride as well which
may sound odd but it's our men and women
who care about the policing of London
who
've given most the evidence for that
report to Louise Casey which is a
testament to their commitment when
police officer Wayne cousins murdered
Sarah everard his case prompted the
first victim to report serial rapist
David Carrick and one of his victims
told us that she was left so traumatized
she feared all uniformed police officers
I would just freeze stop breathing in my
mind I was just straight away thinking
they're going to harm me
what does the police need to do to win
back your trust
I think they need to to go through the
force and that every single guy that is
working there
yeah
and even if there was a mention of a
minor domestic violence argument to
fully investigate it among many
recommendations the report calls for a
new independent team to deal with
misconduct cases end-to-end vetting of
police officers during their time in
service and disbanding the Parliamentary
and diplomatic protection unit of which
both cousins and Carrick were members
it's nearly 25 years since the
MacPherson review found that the police
was institutionally racist now not only
are they bound to be racist but also
misogynistic and homophobic what is the
government going to do about this well
the report is clear that there are
systemic and chronic problems with
leadership and culture and what we need
to do is change the culture change the
practice and change the systems in place
that are running and regulating the met
and that depends on the leadership
this report chastises the Met for
failing to respond to so many other
reports it talks about Hollow promises
fake change a failure to accept the
truth and perhaps the overriding theme
from Louise Casey is that the police
needs to end defensiveness and denials
and take it on the chin because if the
murder of a Woman by a police officer
can't need to change then nothing will
Louise Casey says leadership has till
now repeatedly failed and it is
leadership she hopes that will in Time
Repair the damage Jason Farrell Sky News